why did you bring up the fact that you
had had sex with Andy I was will take
him back I think by her demeanor and
very cold little cold had I plan on and
I think maybe I would have tried to be a
little bit more delicate but that being
said I mean it was something that
weighed on my heart and weighing on my
mind and it wasn't just about the sax
it was more to me about the intimacy and
like I said the fiance type stuff and I
think maybe if I could have just a tart
articulated that a little bit more now
that we know that you guys did make love
you know had sex was the chemistry
lacking in that wake at that about I
mean not in my mind no I mean I the
whole the whole experience like what I
loved about the relationship they've had
is how much we both you know throughout
when you watch it back we both talk
about our emotional and a mental and
physical connection I mean ya know it
was I mean I felt good about it was
effortless you're blushing over there
now you're still in love with her now
I think Monday night was a lot of
closure for me that I needed not
necessarily about the question but again
her whole demeanor in the process
[Music]